Table football was first patented by a
British inventor in 1923.
It became popular throughout Europe with
leagues forming by the 1950s.
A decade later, an American working in West
Germany brought the game to the US,
trademarking the German word for it
foosball.
In France, the game of foosball is known as
Babyfoot.
This company produces ready made as well as
custom made tables like this one featuring
biker players.
Production begins at a foundry where workers
melt down bars of aluminum.
An injection molding machine shoots the
molten aluminum into molds in the shape of
players. A robot removes the casting from
the injection machine.
The mold yields four players, each one
sporting the manufacturer's name on the front
of his jersey. A worker places each casting
on a press, then with one strike separates
the four players and cuts off excess metal.
A computer guided machine drills a hole in
the center of each player through which the
rod will pass.
Then the machine threads a hole through the
players back for the screw that secures the
player to the rod.
Another machine saws a two millimeter gap in
the back to allow clearance for a screwdriver
to tighten the player onto the rod.
Once ready, the players move to the foosball
table factory where a worker sprays on a base
coat of white paint.
Once that dries, workers continue painting
the players, but now using an airbrush, they
mask the players body to paint only his
head.
The company offers a selection of skin tones.
Then they mask the player with another
stencil covering the skin and exposing the
shirt and socks.
Next. They mask everything except the
player's head and feet.
A player can be brunette, blonde or redhead.
They paint the shoes black.
Then the player's eyes and mouth.
Manufacturers construct the table out of
solid beech.
A computer guided milling machine profiles
the wood components, drills the required
holes, and engraves the company name.
Workers then assemble the parts, starting
with the four sides which connect with bolted
steel rods and glue.
After closing up the ends with wood panels,
workers install wood support bars, which will
reinforce the table and after a goal, direct
the ball to the ball return tray.
The table now goes to the paint shop where
workers either stay in the wood or leave it
natural. For this model, they also spray red
stain into the recessed stripes and logo.
All tables receive a finishing code of
transparent varnish to protect the wood.
They install the sloped ball return panel.
When a player scores, the ball rolls down
the panel to an aluminum ball return tray.
After sliding the plywood table bottom into
place, workers turn the table right side up.
Mount the aluminum goal nets and the scoring
units right behind them.
Then they lay the playing surface made of
green vinyl on pressed wood on top of the
wooden support bars.
Wood trim around the perimeter holds the
surface in place.
A worker mounts the players for each line
onto a hollow stainless steel rod using a
template to space them correctly.
He bolts each player to the rod, then
attaches a rubber bumper to the players at
each end to prevent them from slamming
against the side walls.
He inserts a narrower stainless steel rod
into the hollow bar to make it telescopic.
After preparing eight rounds of players, a
worker installs them in the table.
The telescoping handle end of the rod has a
spring loaded bearing that fits in a hole in
the table. He secures it from the outside.
After bolting the opposite end, workers
protect the top edge of the table with a
plastic trim.
After threading plastic handles to the
telescopic end of the rods and mounting the
tables on four sturdy, solid wood legs, this
foosball table is ready for kickoff.
Marseille Soap is a vegetable oil based
soap, first handcrafted in the port city of
Marseille, France, in the Middle Ages.
This gentle, hypoallergenic all purpose
block soap became prized across Europe for
washing clothes, dishes, floors and
cleansing oneself.
Marseilles soap is crafted from just four
traditional ingredients with no animal fats,
colorants perfumes or preservatives.
It's still produced today, as it has been
for more than 600 years.
The four ingredients are sea salt water.
On the right caustic soda and either coconut
oil, palm oil or most often, olive pomace
oil. The second oil extracted from olives
after they've been pressed to extract virgin
olive oil for consumption.
A worker releases the required quantities of
oil and caustic soda into a cooking cauldron,
then brings the mixture to a boil while
stirring for 1 to 2 days.
The fatty acids in the oil react to the
alkaline caustic soda, producing a thick soap
paste containing glycerin, a natural
compound.
This transformation is known as
Saponification.
Workers add more caustic soda and cook at
248°F for another day.
They wash the paste with salt water 2 or 3
times each, washing lasting half a day.
This removes impurities and glycerine
without glycerine.
The soap has better detergent power to
remove grease stains on fabric.
Next. Over the course of a day, the workers
repeatedly rinse the boiling soap paste with
fresh water. Then they let it set for two
days.
They reheat the paste for about ten minutes
at 158°F, just to soften it enough to be
pumped to a series of superheaters.
The superheaters heat the paste to 230°F
liquefying it.
As the liquid soap leaves the last
superheater, it passes through a nozzle which
sprays it onto the walls of an atomizer.
The atomizer calls the soap under vacuum,
solidifying it into a dry moldable
consistency. Motorized blades, then scrape
the dried soap from the atomizer walls.
The soap falls directly into an extrusion
machine, which works much like a pasta maker.
The machine forces the soap through small
round dies as revolving blades chop it into
noodles. As the soap noodles fall onto the
conveyor belt, the soap workshop chief
inspects the quality by assessing the
colour, the aroma and the texture.
At the company's in-house lab, a technician
conducts quality control tests on samples
drawn from each production run.
In this test, he measures the percentage of
pure soap.
He weighs the sample, then heats it in a
microwave oven for ten minutes to evaporate
all the moisture.
This leaves only pure soap without water.
He relays the sample to calculate the
percentage of pure soap.
As well as the oil content, which must be
72%.
The factory sells a portion of its Marseille
soap noodles to companies who mold their own
soap bars. It also molds a house brand right
here, compressing the noodles into a
homogeneous paste, then extruding a long
continuous bar, an automated guillotine
slices the bar into the selected shape.
The conveyor belt ferries the cubes to the
stamping machine, which stamps all six sides.
Each cue bears the company's name and logo.
The soap's oil content and the Savon de
Marseille designation, attesting that this is
indeed authentic, traditionally made
Marseilles soap.